[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de ce mardi 6 février les
yvelines toujours en alerte orange neige
verglas l'épisode devrait s'intensifier
cette nuit dans cette édition nous
ferons le point sur la météo des
prochaines heures et sur la mobilisation
des communes face aux chutes de neige
nous parlerons également sécurité
routière avec notre invité le major
stéphane daquo de la police nationale
comme chaque mardi le portrait de la
rédaction ce soir il est consacré à une
jeune golfeuse de 17 ans mathilde de
claix 7 en sport-études
elle fait partie des meilleurs espoirs
de sa génération là sportifs
s'entraînent au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tout en
préparant son baccalauréat scientifique
et puis le premier tome d'une longue
série de sept livres est sorti il y a
vingt ans en france harry potter
continue de marquer les générations à
l'anniversaire du plus célèbre des
sorciers a été célébré ce week end au
furet du nord au centre commercial sqy
ouest
et puis dans ce journal nous parlerons
également à des 40 ans du conservatoire
de plaisir ils seront fêtés demain en
grande pompe avec une soirée au théâtre
espace coluche toujours à plaisir et les
yvelines se sont réveillés ce matin sous
la neige le département est placé en
vigilance orange neige verglas l'épisode
a débuté hier et devrait à s'intensifier
dans la nuit avec nous par téléphone
damien griffo il est prévisionniste au
centre départemental de météo france à
trappes à la neige damien griffo qui est
tombée ce matin
depuis ce matin aux quantités comment va
évoluer la situation dans les prochaines
heures
en fin de nuit on est sur des cumuls
potentiel de neige de l'ordre de 2,8 à
15 cm en général un peu moins en se
rapprochant de paris où là on va être
plutôt être sur 5 à 9 cm et localement
on pourrait avoir sur le plateau de
trappes jusqu'à 20 cm c'est les seuls
restent encore assez chaud donc pour
l'instant aujourd'hui ça avait tendance
à fondre sur les chaussées mais avec la
nuit ça va tenir de plus en plus et donc
ça fait vraiment un épisode neigeux
remarquable pour pour l'île de france
pour la région c'est quand même
des valeurs assez remarquable voilà donc
ces chutes de neige vont se s'estomper
progressivement en matinée de demain et
donc vont devenir de plus en plus
anecdotique donc voilà on voit la fin en
cours de matinée
damien griffo prévisionniste au centre
départemental de météo france à trappes
on précise qu'un nouvel épisode neigeux
est prévu pour vendredi et vous pouvez
retrouver toutes les informations et les
prévisions à météo les dernières
prévisions à météo sur le site de météo
france
face à l'épisode neigeux les
collectivités s'organisent les services
de voirie tourne à plein régime depuis
plusieurs heures notamment ceux de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et de la ville de montigny le
bretonneux reportage de marie lehn
iapichino camille lambert et mélanie
poté prudence sur les routes et
chinoises l'épisode neigeux annoncé par
météo france s'intensifie pour permettre
aux véhicules de circuler sur les 200 km
de routes de la métropole de saint
quentin en yvelines
les saleuses sont en pleine action
[Musique]
puisque les routes ce sont aussi les
trottoirs qu'il faut dégager dans la
commune de montigny le bretonneux
on suit attentivement les prévisions
teintées de rouge donc ça veut dire
c'est pas bon signe mais c'est pas parce
que c'est rouge que c'est dramatique
la commune réalise une véritable veille
météorologique grâce à un logiciel très
précis jusqu'à 11 heures du matin demain
il va neiger sans cesse pour le moment
les prévisions ne sont pas si alarmante
entre 17h et minuit
il va tomber entre 1 cm et 1 cm 3 de
neige à l'heure
et comme les sols sont très humide donc
la neige
elle va pas forcément tenir les tableaux
accompagnés d'image radars permettent à
la ville d'anticiper hier après-midi les
abords des crèches et des écoles ont été
préparés toutes les équipes du service
technique sont mobilisés depuis 7h ce
matin opération salage 90 tonnes de sel
sont en stock des réserves qui sont les
mêmes depuis deux ans j'ai cinq
personnes agl du manège des petits
engins motorisés
et sinon on est aux douze équipes de
trois personnes sur toute la commune
pour resaler tout ce qui est écoles
crèches dégager les passages piétons
dégager les arrêts de bus et dégage est
toujours le même au moins un trottoir
sur de l'opération se poursuit demain
pour les différents services techniques
de l'agglomération et avant que tous
soient déneigées
certains comptent bien en profiter et
une information qui vient de nous
parvenir de la préfecture tous les
services de transports scolaires ne
seront pas assurés pour la journée de
demain du côté des routes
départementales les agents restent
également mobilisés 24 heures sur 24 les
yvelines qui ont mutualisé depuis peu
avec les hauts-de-seine le service de
viabilité hivernale est pour ce soir
pour les personnes qui seraient bloqués
notamment à elancourt la ville
d'elancourt qui met en place un système
d'accueil dans ces gymnases de gymnase
réquisitionné les gymnases chastagner et
le complexe sportif de l'europe pour les
transports enfin pas de perturbations
majeures sur le fair et le trafic des
lignes n et u est ralentie et sur le
réseau des skis bus la ligne à 475 qui
rallie paris effectue son terminus
exceptionnellement à saint quentin en
yvelines
je précise que la situation peut bien
sûr évoluer dans les prochaines heures
on va parler de sécurité routière dans
un instant mais tout de suite cette
information le mystère plane toujours à
méricourt rappelez-vous ce week-end 250
tonnes de déchets s'étaient accumulés au
niveau du un barrage sur la scène à
cause des inondations ces mêmes déchets
ont semble-t-il disparu depuis hier et
pour une raison inconnue et 8000 m²
d'immondices évaporé voies navigables de
france assure que les cluses n'a pas été
ouverte et que les déchets ont peut-être
été emmenés par des courants vers un
autre bras de la seine les élus du
secteur prévoit de saisir les autorités
un invité m'a rejoint en plateau c'est
le major stéphane d2 caubon soir bonsoir
vous êtes référent police population
pour la circonscription d'agglomération
d'elancourt alors je précise que cette
agglomération regroupe les commissariat
d'elancourt de trappes et de guyancourt
je précise également que vous êtes
intervenant départemental pour la
sécurité routière il devait y avoir avec
nos également sur ce plateau le
capitaine et dick lebeau pour la
gendarmerie à nationale malheureusement
retenu sur les routes ce soir il n'a pas
pu être présent on va parler avec vous
sécurité routière forcément la neige
d'abord une période on imagine nouveaux
services sont pleinement mobilisées pour
activement par donc effectivement leur
moi j'arrive de rambouillet à l'instant
je peux vous dire que c'est très très
très glissant le temps que le sale on
sale comment les routes et que ça fasse
effet avec le nombre d'obèses qui a mais
le problème c'est qu'il ya des bouchons
donc ça ne roule pas donc ça sera
certainement verglacée prudence prudence
et bien sûr on peut recommander aussi
aux automobilistes de surtout éviter le
freinage garder le frein moteur comme on
dit éviter les coups de volant et puis
avoir sa vitesse très très très adapté
on le voit de toute façon puisque là
c'est un petit peu
ce soir tout les tous les véhicules sont
malheureusement un petit peu l'un
derrière l'autre comme si qui avait
beaucoup de bouchons mais ça c'est
normal vis-à-vis des entreprises
malheureusement et dans cette période la
police est mobilisée comme alors et ces
opérations c'est vrai que on a beaucoup
de
de personnels mobilisés en cas de
problématiques liées aux accidents alors
en premier lieu c'est souvent des
accidents matériels d'accord qu'il faut
déblayer les routes etc
les pompiers doivent aussi accéder pour
pouvoir justement sauver des vies donc
on est fortement mobilisée avec des
véhicules adaptés avec des pneus adaptés
puis mon collègue ben voilà donc ils
sont un petit peu comme tout le monde
ils ont parfois des difficultés à
arriver donc il faut aussi être un peu
patient parce que ben forcément avec les
intempéries climatiques
bon bah même les véhicules de police
avec leurs gyrophares de temps ben on va
pas non plus se mettre en danger et
mettre en danger la vie des gens et on
imagine un travail commun beaucoup de
contacts avec les services de la
préfecture avec les pompiers avec les
communes aussi alors je pense que quand
il ya un événement comme ce soir et
comme dans les prochains jours il ya
beaucoup de corrélation entre les
services institutionnels de secours avec
la préfecture
et puis les services départementaux de
la sécurité publique et la gendarmerie
également et on a pu le voir notamment
sur l'épisode des inondations qui était
la semaine
cantine et les ja voilà c'est
déjà deux épisodes compliqué alors vous
êtes venu majors des deux coups pour
nous parler ce soir de sécurité routière
et notamment le bilan de l'année 2010
est dans les yvelines avec 49 personnes
ont trouvé la mort l'an passé sur les
routes du département c'est une de plus
par rapport à 2016 les jeunes qui sont
particulièrement touchés dans le même
temps le nombre de blessés d'accidents
corporels sont en baisse quel bilan vous
tirez vous sur la zone police qu'avez
vous constaté notamment sur peut-être
l'évolution des incivilités sur
l'évolution des causes des accidents
alors écoutez c'est vrai que moi ça fait
quand même depuis très longtemps qu'on
fait de la sécurité routière et c'est
vrai qu'on remarque depuis un certain
nombre d'années notamment l'année
dernière et l'année d'avant on a de plus
en plus des piétons un là on a onze
piétons qui sont décédés malheureusement
et des comportements d'incivilité
notamment des repas forcément les plus
jeunes mais c'est parfois nouveau lot
même en étant pied temps on a les
smartphones complètement scotché à
l'oreille on ne voit pas la voiture qui
va pas s'arrêter et ses passages piétons
on a aussi des comportements bien sûr
comment la route et c'est vrai qu'on
s'est retrouvé confronté à des personnes
qui avaient constamment les textos le
téléphone au volant
pas forcément du les accidents mortels à
l'alcool ou au cannabis même si ça
existe bien sûr notamment on a des des
changements de comportements enfin c'est
pas forcément des changements mais un
problème général de comportement fait et
on s'aperçoit que finalement valence est
où se trouvent les radars on prend
beaucoup plus de routine ont ces voix là
et on a l'impression que tu es personnes
finale membres voisins c'est comme ça
donc on va utiliser de téléphone on va
peut-être avoir des des problématiques
on va dire par rapport à la voiture on
se croit tout permis
la courtoisie au volant là on a
complètement oublié il se peut que m'a
un jour ben j'ai pas vu un piéton je
fais signe de la main je m'excuse
alors ça des gestes comme ça qu'on va
pas souvent malheureusement néanmoins on
est tous ceux concernés 1
bien sûr sur la route et qu' il faut
savoir une chose est que la voiture peut
devenir une arme par destination et ça
peut tuer des gens malheureusement alors
49 personnes mortes sur les routes
chinoises en 2010 est comment travailler
laissez vos services de police peut-être
des actions de sensibilisation et aussi
des opérations j'imagine qu'ils sont
mises en place sur l'ailé alors c'est
vrai que au delà de la répression
moi je fais partie des années des idées
ciel qui faisons de la prévention alors
s'ouvrir dans les scolaires dans les
entreprises au sein de deux des
institutions et aussi au sein des
collectivités territoriales donc ça
c'est un une mesure qui est constante
sur l'année et mais on met en place
aussi des opérations massives un de
répression de contrôle routier de
contrôle vitesse de contrôle alcoolémie
parfois c'est en adéquation aussi avec
les la gendarmerie sur les zones de
compétences et donc c'est vrai qu'au
cours de ces opérations là bas on
s'aperçoit qu'on est quand même presque
à 10000 contrôle sur l'année dix mille
opération pardon voilà pratiquement sur
l'année 2010 est donc ça veut dire que
la police ne fait rien maintenant c'est
vrai qu'il ya des comportements qu'on
aperçoit et dès qu'on a nous une
personne qui malheureusement est à soit
franchi un feu rouge ou soi n'est pas en
mesure d'être en bons termes avec le
code de la route et bien forcément il ya
des sanctions et on sait qu'aujourd'hui
un téléphone au volant basse et des
points
le franchissement d'une continue et
cetera font que ben on perd beaucoup de
points on a des amendes certes mais les
points ça arrive très vite et donc il y
en a qui roulent sans avoir un permis
avec des points donc ça s'appelle un
solde de points nul ça c'est interdit et
en tout cas vous pouvez retrouver toutes
les informations sur la sécurité
routière sur le site du gouvernement il
s'affiche en bas de l'écran www.ac
curité attiré routière point gouv.fr
merci majors des deux co d'avoir été
avec elle ça vous est donc je le précise
je le rappelle vous êtes tant que major
de police et
vous intervenez sur la circonscription
d'elancourt qui donc on prend les
commissariats également de trappes et de
guyancourt merci d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous dans le reste de
l'actualité une nouvelle gourmand le
guide michelin a révélé hier son
palmarès 2018 et un restaurant yvelinois
fait son entrée dans le cercle très
fermé des établissements étoilés le
domaine de la corniche et son restaurant
le panoramic harold poisson chef julien
heureusement est récompensé pour sa
cuisine moderne et créative les sept
autres restaurants une étoile du
département eux conservent leurs
distinctions notamment l'angélique le
gordon ramsay ou encore la table du 11 à
versailles un geste de solidarité à
présent à montigny le bretonneux
l'entreprise saint-quentinoise 50 un
bâtiment a fait don d'une remorque à la
section hand fauteuil de la smb handball
remise officielle hier de cet équipement
chiffré à 2500 euros
il va faciliter la logistique pour la
section qui fête cette année ses 11 ans
tous les fauteuils roulants de l'équipe
vont pouvoir être chargé sur la remorque
pour se rendre aux entraînements mais
aussi aux rencontres à l'extérieur
propos reccueillis par patrick jacques
de dixmude et quentin le frère nous
avions déjà des fauteuils et là en fait
il nous fallait un moyen pour être
autonome dans le sens de nos
déplacements
et avec 50 un bâtiment on a trouvé un
partenaire va tout simplement qui nous a
offert cette remorque que vous voyez
derrière et qui nous permet de
transporter l'ensemble des fauteuils
pour transporter l'équipe n'importe où
en france attachement morale attachement
humains des valeurs qui je pense se perd
de plus en plus c'est que je souhaite
vraiment remettre aujourd'hui au goût du
jour dans ma ville mais comme chaque
mardi tv 78 vous propose un portrait
aujourd'hui direction le golf national
de saint quentin en yvelines
coup de projecteur projecteurs pardon
sur mathilde claisse cette jeune athlète
de 17 ans et en sport études puis à 5
ans et partage son temps entre sa
passion le golf et ses études à quelques
mois du bac un reportage de michael et
demi d'euros et patrick jacques de
dixmude le monde a découvert son visage
aux côtés du golfeur thomas ce viol en
octobre dernier pour la journée ryder
cup au golf national va-t-il de classe
17 ans fait partie des golfeuses
françaises les plus doués de sa
génération
l'envers du décor et plus studieux la
jeune yvelinoise intégrer une section
sport étude de la fédération française
puis 50 premiers trucs à faire on
vérifie d'éléments en commun donc entre
eux cet occident et son réducteur
associer ses caractéristiques de quoi
dans une solution j'aurais dit à cette
voie là ça dans cette classe aménagée au
golf national mathilde suit des cours
petit groupe de quatre élèves
la sportive passe en moyenne cinq heures
par jour loin des greens pour préparer
son bac scientifique
j'ai la partie des gens statut de
sportive au niveau de l' éducation
nationale de passer mon bac en deux ans
donc j'ai séparer les matières et donc
ça me facilite la tâche un peu ça donne
plus de temps pour faire les deux pour
gérer les deux une fois les cours
terminés direction les terrains de golf
l'athlète qui a commencé ce sport à 5
ans à villennes-sur-seine tape la balle
une vingtaine d'heures chaque semaine le
gall va prêter même si j'ai un bac et
faut que je fasse des études après mais
c'est d'abord le golfe et ouais je
préfère passer du temps à m'entraîner
que soient les sessions incluse dans le
programme sport études sont encadrés par
un coach national
elles doivent lui permet d'accéder aux
grands tournois mondiaux pour atteindre
le haut niveau elles sont obligées
d'augmenter la quantité de
l'entraînement et
c'est pour ça que cette structure a été
créée un entraînement intensif sur le
plan golfique dans tous les facteurs de
performance ont à la fois sur la partie
technique sur la dimension physique
donc tout est organisé autour de ça pour
mettre là je la joue dans l'est dans les
meilleures conditions
voilà plus devant toi à travers
je pense que ça aide beaucoup les filles
qui sont par une structure comme nous je
sais qu'elles ont beaucoup de mal
surtout en terminale mais qui a le bac
c'est vraiment dur de concilier les deux
et nous bat wav aiff bien grâce à sa
savane eu plus de bars une idée pour
m'entraîner il progressait à bathilde
envisage maintenant de partir aux usa
dans une faculté pour continuer à jouer
sur les deux tableaux le golf et les
études avec un objectif en tête
participer aux jo de 2024 qui seront
organisés à saint quentin en yvelines
un anniversaire à plaisir le crc
conservatoire à rayonnement communal
fête ses 40 ans cette année pour en
parler avec mon plateau abri savoir un
métairie bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
conseiller municipal à plaisir délégué
aux actions culturelles alors le
conservatoire fête ses 40 ans demain il
ya une grande soirée organisée au
théâtre espace coluche on va en parler
dans un instant à développer le
programme 40 ans pour pour ce
conservatoire ça représente quoi pour la
ville bah c'est quand même centrale dans
l'action politique culturelle de la
ville juste pour en quelques dates
ça a commencé en 1977 avec quatre
professeurs très vite ça s'est agrandie
et dix ans après on est arrivé au
château
en suite en 2005 le conservatoire est
effectivement devenu été agréé
conservatoire à rayonnement culturel
d'accord donc voilà un événement
important dans la politique dans la
politique culturelle de la ville de
plaisir vous avez parlé du château
puisque conservatoire est
essentiellement basé sur le château mais
il ya plusieurs sites également à
travers la la ville de plaisir oui
effectivement le conservatoire
principalement sur le château lui on a
quatre sites sur lesquels rayonne le
conservatoire la clé des champs leur
conservatoire de danse et la maison des
familles camille claudel avoir un
conservatoire aussi important quarante
ans d'existence sur le territoire voyez
quel quelle importance pour la ville de
plaisir vous les voulez d'une ville
résolument tourné vers l'action
culturelle quelle importance ou et pour
pur plaisir ses 40 ans a permis aussi de
mettre en exergue la qualité du travail
qui est fait par par l'ensemble des
professeurs et du prix du pardon du
directeur du conservatoire de la ville
de plaisir
et effectivement l'idée c'était vraiment
de marquer ses 40 ans au travers toute
l'évolution avec un rayonnement communal
et j'allais dire même au delà que ce
soit sur l'intercommunalité ou même au
delà presque départementale aujourd'hui
donc intercommunalités haut avec des
villes par exemple autour de plaisir les
clayes-sous-bois villepreux notamment
alors si on représente le conservatoire
quelques l enseignement il dispense
qu'elle paul finalement on peut
retrouver dans ce conservatoire à
rayonnement communal
alors on a quatre pôles un pôle musique
paul dans ce pôle théâtre et pôle arts
et sciences et ses quatre pôles
effectivement seront représentés demain
lors de la soirée les 40 ans du
conservatoire
peut-être aussi rappelé quelques
quelques chiffres sur ce conservateur
ses 1200 élèves qui sont reçues toutes
les semaines dans les différents sites
du conservatoire d'accord c'est près de
quarante professeurs donc voilà quelque
chose de d'important sur sur la ville de
plaisir qui met en avant la ville de
plaisir et rayonne sur plaisir et au
delà alors s'était mise en avant lors
notamment des portes ouvertes à la
rentrée 2010 est au au conservatoire il
ya le numérique aussi qui a pris une
place importante notamment sur les
méthodes d'enseignement et même les
créations qui sont réalisés au sein du
conservatoire
effectivement c'est la partie pôle arts
et sciences la partie numérique
l'objectif c'est c'est d'amener la
culture aussi verser milieu numérique
c'est quelque chose qui est qui et jédir
d'actualité et qui va au delà de
l'actualité plutôt dans le futur aussi
côté musique un projet orchestre camille
qui est mise en place avec une pratique
de l'orchestré ça c'est dès les
premières années d'apprentissage
effectivement l'objectif c'est de
vraiment faire découvrir la culture et
tout type de culture via le
conservatoire est donc effectivement la
partie orchestre également dès le début
que vous montrez au conservatoire et
enfin vous vouliez de mettre en avant
mais béziers tout à l'heure en off
il ya une filière théâtre qui est
également à la pointe au conservatoire
de plaisir c'est la seule filière
horaires aménagés théâtre du département
et voilà des filières innovantes
finalement pour ces étudiants est
exactement encore une fois sa montre
la qualité des professeurs et de ce
conservatoire le seul et l'unique dans
le département à avoir des horaires
aménagés pour pouvoir pratiquer le
théâtre en tout en continuant ses études
et en ayant des professeurs de grande
qualité on précise d'ailleurs que ses
élèves à se représenter régulièrement
aux concours nationaux on va terminer
cette interview sur la soirée demain
soir et des quarante ans au théâtre
espace coluche à plaisir c'est à 20h30
alors une forêt qui est malheureusement
déjà complètes
quel est le programme demain alors dès
19h30 le public sera accueilli avec une
proposition d'une proposition
d'exposition numérique justement
et proposer ce que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure par la pollution c'est numérique
et ça permettra au public de voyager sur
les 40 dernières années en proposant
quatre kiosques
permettant au public de ceux de se
plonger successivement pardon des années
80 à nos jours avec une création
numérique et sonore ni visuelle pardon
les sonars le public sera également
accueilli au son des premiers groupes et
ensembles musicaux qui souhaiteront
parlant mélodies la bienvenue à tous
pour cette soirée mémorable
un événement qu'on la dit complet au
théâtre espace coluche ça veut dire ça
que les habitants de plaisir sont
attachés à leur alors conservatoire
exactement
j'allais dire les habitants de plaisir
est effectivement l'ensemble des élèves
du conservatoire sont mobilisés pour
fêter ses 40 ans le précise cette soirée
donc c'est demain à partir de 20h30 au
théâtre espace coluche je le rappelle
l'événement a malheureusement déjà
complet en tout cas vous pouvez
retrouver l'actualité du conservatoire
sur le site de la ville de plaisir qui à
sa fiche en bas d'écran merci à brice
savoir un métairie d'avoir été avec nous
ici à bout et je le rappelle vous êtes
conseiller municipal délégué aux actions
culturelles à la ville de plaisir
autre anniversaire pour refermer ce
journal vous connaissez forcément à ce
célèbre sorcier à lunettes à la
cicatrice en forme d'éclair harry potter
a fait ses 20 ans le premier tome harry
potter à l'école des sorciers sortie
pour apple en 1998 ce week-end plusieurs
lieux ont célébré l'événement comme le
furet du nord au centre commercial sqy
ouest à montigny le bretonneux avec
camille lambert et nicolas landry ont pu
rencontrer quelques fans
tu l'as jacques son nom est désormais
connu dans le monde rex et harry potter
le jeune sorcier de jk rowling une
aventure commencée en 1998 avec un
premier tome il ya 20 ans harry entrée à
l'école des sources
[Musique]
cher monsieur potter nous avons le
plaisir de vous informer que vous êtes
admis qu au collège de l'art l'école de
sorcellerie à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
ses fans sont venus célébrer cet
anniversaire aux couleurs de la saga
j'ai la robe des forces et des effets
sonores
ouais j'ai la baguette d'harry potter
j'ai les lunettes d'harry potter
la cicatrice de harry potter et j'ai les
joueurs de la caf au nord là c'est ce
pion ou la salle en français et c'est
l'association d'hermione pour la défense
des elfes de maison et ça c'est une
baguette fait part ces petits soins
toujours c'est une baguette qui
inspirait par la baguette de sirius
black répartition dans les maisons à
l'aide du choix peau atelier
calligraphie pour réaliser son blason
différents ateliers mis en place par
cette enseigne de sqy ouest
je crois que harry potter ça a changé
toute une génération que sur 15 20 ans
tous les jeunes on a été transformé par
ce petit sorcier et et il a vécu un peu
la vie qu'on a tous envie de vivre donc
voilà ça me fait rêver
une saga qui poursuit sa conquête
l'univers harry potter continue de vivre
au travers de films comme les animaux
fantastiques sortie en 2016
il avait attiré près de 4 millions de
spectateurs dans les salles françaises
par les nomma agents peur et les
attaques régler ça où ce sera la guerre
là c'est la fin de ce statut de journal
on vous rappelle la principale
information de cette édition les
yvelines qui sont toujours placés ce
soir en vigilance orange neige verglas
l'épisode neigeux qui devrait
s'intensifier dans la nuit retrouver
toutes les prévisions sur le site de
météo france du côté des routes
départementales rappelle également avec
les agents restent mobilisés 24 heures
sur 24
du côté des services de scolaires les
services de ramassage scolaire qui ne
seront pas assurées demain précise la
préfecture du département
à côté transports enfin pas de
perturbation majeure pour le moment sur
le fair et le trafic des lignes n et u
est ralentie et sur le réseau stibus la
ligne 4 175 qui relie paris effectue son
terminus ce soir à saint quentin en
yvelines
la situation peut bien évidemment
évoluer
ici les prochaines heures cette édition
vous pouvez la retrouver en replay sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile tv soixante dix huit belles
soirées et prudents avec la neige
[Musique]